watch him to this video play
international master fly away from the
Minya fly away too far something yeah no
name in that but the mania has some
cheap why the number of I am so I guess
okay my own favorite in the scotch and
actually yeah there are some minion
players who were who who play that line
you should be for check evil Aronian did
play it more than once okay so on he
played this can of set up with the maroc
see point type of position and i think
i'm already made a mistake i played this
too quickly it's not fatal but it's not
so great what I did you can also delay
the capture this was really a bit in
precise
yeah yeah here I'm always suffering from
this lack of space this night night to
d5 those kind of moves
oh this is some very ambitious
yeah maybe maybe you can do that la
White has a really big Center and it's
not like am I have much gotta play yet
mmm came
yeah but I shouldn't be mated to quickly
here h5 the screen g5 so this is not not
such a big problem
yeah yeah it looks very scary but ok
maybe I need to I need to get some count
to play with pieces like nighter night
before or something is free this b3 this
is this is not helping yeah I needed to
I would need to need to get b5 going
here but how don't really see how 95s
it's not working at all
hmm
yeah I don't know what to do it's very
passive I cannot I don't have any porn
breaks and this is almost always a
problem no porn break means drawing what
I'm trying to do is play c60 mc6 if it
wraps on d6 play Queen B 6 try to get
near the king and maybe in yeah maybe he
allows yeah Queen B 6 is the only only a
kind of play maybe night b3m type III is
also an idea Queen B 6 9 p-3 a Bab and
then then the a file or something maybe
maybe probably he can just take the sex
not sure but maybe
yeah maybe it is not so clear-cut c6 was
probably the only moon at least from a
human point of view maybe the computer
refuted wow what a means when he took
took his sweet time so I thought okay he
needs to do something good now I take on
a to what is it doing Knight f6 maybe it
takes with Paul twin before him
let's let's do that this looks really
strange I know but what is he doing now
I'm just attacking the knight now if you
return so i can play night before but I
have also other moves can play a three
for instance or queen bee six yeah could
be six actually okay so here also clean
be six green be six attending a three
okay so he wants to really make me on g7
yeah this is not nice really so III will
be tuned and now Knight takes be three
year why not why not check this is
predicting
so let's check Queenie 3m this was my
idea it's working i think not see to the
the fork and it was saying so queen
before Queenie to my yes this at the end
okay so hmm what's now
he's threatening f7 M is threatening of
sim
I want to I want to stay active yet try
to attack myself maybe it is it is not
working I don't know look b5 as my dear
which looks completely weird yeah that
is weird but okay at least his son
compel to to think a bit
check check it shouldn't be bad check my
gift this check Patsy's a check and
gives a check what I'm just running I'm
right into the fork just this is just
idiotic check yeah i was i was
completely ok maybe even better check I
really idiotic check yeah this is easy
no surely try what a stupid game I'm
running right into this damn fork
completely unnecessary I just have the
the bishop against the night in this
position and I've got I've got pawns
myself just idiotic ok I can even do
that him and black is perfectly all
right with three connected passers this
is worth nothing besides the fact that i
probably had chances before Adam yeah
everything's ok yeah I'm just a bit a
bit pissed off here because I had this
really difficult position and found a
really good defense and at the end what
do you get nothing because you give this
bloody stupid check it was a very
interesting game I mean I don't know
maybe add other moves but this was
interesting chant ok could have I could
have played Quincy for was maybe even
better chocolate
and it didn't have much time but running
right into this fog is so idiotic I can
even take a five now which I didn't see
and of course this loser straight away
yeah this was stupid around here it was
really interesting and this is G for
what he what he did the some very
aggressive way to play I mean I don't
know what can why does not forced to do
that you can play other things yeah a
three the computer wants to go a three
and refute that okay and this it was all
very interesting and then I'll spoil it
with this idiotic fork yeah yeah okay
what can you do thanks for watching